uh this is super interesting and not all
together
uh surprising the daily beast has a
fascinating piece um somewhat lengthy
not not huge but
uh taking a few minutes to read about
how rudy giuliani
seems to have the walls closing in
around him in terms of these
investigations that are going on
and donald trump seems to have abandoned
him completely which is
absolutely on brand for donald trump
this is a piece in the daily beast which
we will link to written by adam ronsley
and azawin subseng which writes
in the weeks since the feds raided rudy
giuliani's apartment
and office in late april close to close
allies have tried to ferry
a slew of emergency requests to former
president donald trump and his advisors
but according to three people familiar
with the matter trump and his legal
advisors and confidants
have been hesitant about swooping in to
help the embattled giuliani
who for years worked as trump's personal
attorney political advisor and
attack dog understand what's going on
rudy's in trouble the walls are closing
in around rudy
they raided his home they raided his
office it's
looking really bad for rudy and rudy
is sending these massive dumps for lack
of a better term of requests
to trump and his advisors for help for
interference for whatever some kind of
intervention
and trump is just ignoring it uh the
daily beast piece goes on to say
team trump's reluctance to intervene
comes at a time
when federal investigators have ramped
up their probe into whether
giuliani's ukraine-related work during
the trump era amounted to an
unregistered
and illegal lobbying operation on behalf
of foreign figures
so far no charges have been brought
trump's silence has led
to simmering frustrations among members
of giuliani's inner orbit
who privately allege that the
ex-president's team is working to
convince him to hang giuliani out to dry
in his hour of need that's another level
and that would be
absolutely compelling we've been keeping
an eye but not
talking too much about donald trump's
blogs
on his website and so far he has not
come to the defense of rudy giuliani
but he's also not hung rudy giuliani out
to dry
i think that if this escalates and it
gets to the point where
it's clear rudy is going to be charged i
do think trump will publicly abandon
rudy and say
he was he was off script he was doing
his own thing
he was not representing me um one person
close to giuliani
said last week quote it's a question now
of whether or not trump wants to leave
rudy to fend for himself or if they're
going to take a stand against this
right now we don't know among the pleas
like what is rudy asking for among the
pleas
have been for trump to issue a strong
verbal or written statement
saying giuliani's work during the trump
ukraine saga was done on behalf of trump
there's no way in hell trump says that
because trump needs to leave the
possibility if rudy gets charged
of saying the ukraine stuff had nothing
to do with me i had a perfect phone call
and that's it
whatever rudy was doing i don't know
about um
the other asks have been that trump sign
onto a legal motion
to have federal investigators throw out
any seized communications
that rudy and his lawyers are arguing
are covered by attorney-client privilege
and further there have been requests
that trump and his team
financially help rudy in his legal
defense
apparently rudy's legal expenses are
going
absolutely crazy now that's what the
rudy people want trump to do
on the other hand and this is a really
great piece that looks at both sides of
this in the daily beast
two people close to trump they write say
they have urged trump to lay low
and refrain from making too many
statements one way or the other
these people have told trump it's
unclear what the feds have
and anything trump says could backfire
on him and on giuliani that is exactly
why
trump would never come out and say rudy
was working on behalf of me
because they don't know what they have
on rudy yet and if it's really bad if
they have rudy dead to rights
trump now saying everything rudy did he
did it for me
it implicates donald trump so this
shouldn't surprise
anybody who understands how donald trump
operates
look at trump with his voters trump
defends them they're beautiful people
uh there's my african-american and the
hispanics love me and the suburban women
these are all great people
as long as they're useful to him but as
soon as they're not like for example
on january 6th trump turned on the tv
and he saw the rioters who were all
trumpists
and he said these people look kind of
low class they're making me look bad
and then he abandons them um trump
grifting what was it 70 million from his
supporters
for legal battles after the november
election
that were never going to go anywhere
trump scamming his supporters saying i
will fight this and i will
audit that and do a recount here and
more than half the money went just to
pay off trump's uh campaign
debt why because at that point
the election was over the only way that
these people were useful to trump was
trying to grift some money
out of them and it's the same way with
trump's lawyers and cronies
he abandoned michael cohen and
when trump has political allies he loves
them while they're allies as soon as
they some
say something even mildly critical uh
trump abandons them so the one thing
about this
uh that is that is predictable and on
brand
is trump's not going to come to anyone's
defense unless it's useful to him
and right now coming out and saying rudy
did great work and it was all for me
that possibly implicates donald trump
they don't know how bad
uh rudy is in trouble at this point in
time um
one other interesting aspect from this
daily beast article which says quote
in recent weeks trump himself has argued
behind closed doors
that he wouldn't want to say giuliani
was doing all of the ukraine work
which included a transatlantic dirt
digging expedition on the biden family
on trump's behalf trump's reasoning
is based on the ex-president's
insistence that he didn't always know
what giuliani was doing during the
ukraine effort
or concocting with his ukrainian pals
several of whom trump has privately
dinged as
idiots so apparently this is something
trump is saying
privately it's actually possible that
that is to some degree true
but that doesn't tell us trump didn't
have a sense of what was going on very
often
someone in a role as powerful as
president of the united states
would be deliberately kept out of the
loop as to the specifics of what his
henchmen are doing
and when you're in that position you
know you're being kept out of the loop
like in other words
you may you know it's a known unknown
you know you're not being told exactly
what rudy's up to you know the gist of
it
but you're not being told the specifics
in order to keep you potentially out of
trouble
um if something exactly like this would
happen so the last thing anyone would do
in this situation is to say
i knew everything he was doing and he
was doing it all for me now one last
thing here
okay that i this goes back to trump's
narcissism
some people are saying
uh obviously trump
isn't going to help someone who has
mountains of dirt
on him because trump's worried it will
come back on him but
isn't there a risk that rudy if trump
doesn't help him will release all the
dirt he has on trump
trump doesn't think this way trump is a
narcissist
trump cannot conceive of anybody turning
on him in that way
if they did so what he's donald trump
it's not like anything bad can happen
anything donald trump does in his mind
is legal and good because it's something
he did
and that would never happen so i know
you and i might say you know it's a
double-edged sword because on one hand
on the one hand trump doesn't want to
defend giuliani because that could come
back to bite him on the other hand if
trump doesn't
rudy could release whatever dirt he has
on trump trump the narcissist doesn't
think the dirt rudy has could really
damage him in a serious way that's what
you have to remember
about how the narcissist thinks so we'll
see what happens let me know if you
think there are charges forthcoming for
rudy i think uh
i i just don't know and it's not because
i don't think rudy did some horrible
things
it's similar to gates we have a two-tier
justice system in this country we know
that people in positions of power often
are not subject to the same
circumstances that other people are uh
so i just i genuinely don't know what to
expect in terms of charges against rudy
but
let me know your thoughts